two bottles of vodka is this gonna be
the weekend we finally meet six-drink
amy
six-drink amy what does that mean it's
the pinnacle of the Santiago drunkenness
scale one drink
aim is a little Spacey wait what two
drinks loud Amy you want to get a cat
three drinks
Amy dance pants four-drink amy is a bit
of a pervert hey check it out
and five-drink amy is weirdly confident
let's do this little man but I've never
seen
six-drink amy maybe she's the one I
could actually be friends with aka Oh
Santo was a little naughty this is
Christmas spirit as in spirits we can
drink we're really not specific Toby I
mean it's a party come on if I can't
throw a good party for my employees and
I am a terrible boss what's a drink me
here we go
a deal is that this is my last hurrah
cuz I made him New Year's resolution but
I'm not gonna drink anymore during the
week
[Music]
no false modesty my friend you know you
don't have to answer calls during a
party just thought you should know no I
was just checking out my present but I
traded with Dwight um just I figured you
know you went to a lot of trouble and it
means a lot
and also Roy got me an iPod or was going
to get me an iPod so well either way
this is an amazing gift because it comes
with bonus gifts yeah I think I made the
right choice
incredible is it the boggle timer I
didn't think you really let that one I
really did it that is so awesome and if
it couldn't go to Ryan you are the guy
I'd want to go to thank you pac-man need
to drink tea oh let's fix you up who
wants to fix up Toby
nobody's gonna fix you up
[Music]
Daryll there you go
you earned it that's okay Mike oh no no
no no I really really want you to have
it right thanks man hey Merry Christmas
whose butt is that hey Meredith
heading over to Poor Richard's yep cool
you need a ride all right it's time to
settle this an old-fashioned prairie
drink off what's in that jug it smells
like jet fuel that's Swanson family mash
liqueur made from the finest corn ever
grown on American soil
it's only legal use is to strip varnish
off of speedboats if you whinnies all
yours
and if I win I bring him back to the
farm for good wait what that wasn't the
deal pour it I'm thirsty pour me one too
then let me in here I'm gonna join you
and if I win
Ron stays here with us Leslie no don't
drink that we use it to burn warts off
of the Mules poison Oh
I made a mistake I made a mistake
Edna this watered-down baby formula
not even close not even close
Marvin clones Glenn Close we already got
you idiot look who's here
how was your night of old school
drinking hmm pretty hungover turn off
your mouth siren here the text I got
from you last night
best night ever why Scotch burns so good
was his name in Serpico who's the friend
of yours with the ping-pong and lastly a
picture of you on the subway platform
eating Chinese chicken salad with no
shirt on well last night was awesome we
had an epic night of bonding that I will
never forget do it I believe in you
through it I believe in you
I wonder if Brogan's okay he's 65 and
bring two bottles of scotch he might be
dead looks fine to me
morning kid how you doing oh hey so good
I feel great and I definitely don't
think it's burning hot in here well I'm
around grab me if anything develops in
your case you got it so bad let me know
and he's gone so I can slide onto the
nice cool floor he's gone oh my whole
body is dry mouth
this is equal parts scotch
absinthe rum gin vermouth triple sec and
two packs of Splenda call it a one of
everything
oh my god
all right one more time around the buck
[Music]
hey it's really handy it's Christmas and
you're singing about nudity and France
[Music]
Japan Oh what is that that is vodka and
I mixed it with orange juice I call it
an orange juice wow that is delicious
yeah I can't believe no one's tonic I
know
[Music]
oh so this is what everyday would be
like if you hadn't left India
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright alright
every time I cleanse I can literally
feel the toxins leaving my body I know I
feel so much healthier
I've still got a full week to go before
the broth stage hmm free broth is an
amazing stage it's when you're most
alert good
someone needs to be alert tonight this
snake juice is basically rat poison
everybody's wasted you don't even know
what think I didn't even say what they
get it she asked me the whole thing and
I didn't do it what I'm like an elephant
okay if I walk into a room it's like
okay he's in there Baba Booey turns
music down but no I see puck I feel
phenomenal yeah you come into me Kenneth
and I protected then we got in a role
playing in the only body smell trophy
class she worked the bid is this
everybody and to the cab Tom to the
trunk Jerry's on the roof all right
we're to first you Mouse but oh and even
one of you thinking about drying even in
my stars you're all walking
you